All right, I'm sort of depressed that we have
to do this again, but I'm okay with it and
I'm going to keep doing it until it sticks
and it may never stick and it'll just be an
ongoing conference.
[inaudible]
and if that's the case, then so be it.
Bernie Sanders, democratic socialism is not
communism, and in fact, Bernie's democratic
socialism isn't even socialism.
It's actually social democracy, which is a
form of well-regulated capitalism, the number
of emails and is actually going up.
Then I'm getting about this because Bernie
has a shot at the nomination because more
and more people are paying attention to Bernie
Sanders.
The number of emails I get about Bernie communists,
this Bernie socialists, that communism isn't
invalid.
Socialism isn't invalid.
There is a lot to discuss and debate and explore
about both, but Bernie Sanders is running
a campaign of social democracy.
Now, before we dig into this, I know Bernie
often says he's a democratic socialist.
I wish he wouldn't.
He may be a democratic socialist, but he is
running as a social Democrat.
This is a type of capitalism common in Northern
Europe and certain other countries.
Donald Trump calls Bernie a socialist.
Slash.
Communist.
Those are two different things.
Bernie is running as neither.
Now I tried to do some basic definitions so
that we could at at a basic level, compare
and contrast the three ideas.
There are no perfect definitions because there
will be those who envision a specific type
of socialism when they say socialism or when
they say communism, they envision some prototypical
type of communism.
Uh, but I think that this is pretty good as
a starting point for us.
Social democracy is a capitalist economy,
strongly oriented towards social justice.
And we'll talk more about that in a second.
Socialism is a system of social ownership
of the means of production.
And communism is a system of government ownership
These are not perfect definitions, but this
at least helps us draw some lines.
So when you look at this, no matter how you
define this stuff, universal healthcare does
not make a country socialist.
Medicare for all is certainly not a, a guarantee
of communism or socialism.
Capitalist countries with strong welfare policies
are not socialist and they are not communist.
Bernie Sanders does not want to abolish private
property.
Bernie Sanders does not want to mandate socializing
ownership of the means of production.
Bernie wants to democratize the workplace
where individual companies are structured
in a more egalitarian way.
Taxation is used to redistribute wealth to
some degree so that no one standard of living
falls too low.
This is really pretty uncontroversial stuff
and there's a long list of countries, Denmark,
Sweden, Norway, Finland and others that have
uh, socially democratic, uh, systems similar
to what Bernie Sanders is proposing.
Now there's something very interesting about
social democracy versus socialism of social
Democrats versus actual socialists.
There are strict socialists, actual socialists
that are often very much against social Democrats
who propose what Bernie Sanders is proposing.
Why social democracy makes capitalist countries
more equal?
Social democracy makes capitalist countries
healthier, more viable, better functioning.
Social democracy strengthens capitalism.
It takes the edge off of capitalism.
Strict socialists are sometimes unwilling
to see things in shades of gray and they get
mad at social Democrats because they say social
democracy will make people more satisfied
with a capitalist system which we want to
go away.
Making it less likely that there will be a
desire for a revolution in which a country
actually becomes a socialist country.
Now there are many socialists that are more
pragmatic and they realize we are more likely
to eventually get to socialism from social
democracy than from where we are today.
So there are some socialists who from a pragmatic
point of view, welcomed socially democratic
reforms.
Now let's get back to our definitions for
a second just to clarify that even these definitions
are controversial and I understand that there
are some who will say, you know, David, your
definition of social democracy is not really
social democracy, it's welfare capitalism.
And that's something else.
Some will say, you know, the real difference
between communism and socialism isn't that
in one the government owns the means of production
and in the other the people own the means
of production.
The real difference is that communism is a
necessarily revolutionary and it includes
a one-party government and one party rule
where a socialism need not necessarily include
those things.
So I understand that these are not perfect
definitions, but this is a framework to think
these things through.
But the important takeaway is that by any
reasonable definition, Bernie Sanders is not
running on a communist platform and he's not
even running on a socialist platform.
If he is a democratic socialist, then the
platform he is running on is not one.
And that is the really important takeaway
that I hope we can all, uh, uh, sort of integrate
and assimilate into our points
of view.